Hey David, seriously, what is wrong with compulsive
liars like Trump and real life and other people
that I know in real life?
Is it a medical condition?
So there's actually quite a bit of litter
literature about this.
Um, pathological or compulsive lying is a
condition that is named and you know, that
doesn't tell us anything about it one way
or the other.
You can argue that we have overmedicalization
in our society where things that should not
really be diagnosable conditions are diagnosable
conditions, but there is a condition called
pathological lying.
It's the behavior of habitual or, or compulsive
lying.
Uh, some psychiatrists distinguish pathological
lying and compulsive lying.
Others say that it's the same thing.
Um, but the idea is, uh, that um, there is
a medicalization of this phenomena which not
everybody necessarily agrees with.
It's a standalone disorder.
It is often also a symptom of other conditions
like psychopathy and antisocial personality
disorder often will, uh, have compulsive or
pathological lying.
Narcissists often lie compulsively.
People with histrionic personality disorder
often will have pathological or compulsive
lying.
Um, the average onset is 16 years.
And for people who have above average intelligence,
uh, at least average or above average, they
tend to be more likely to develop this condition
of pathological or compulsive lying.
Now, if we want to reject for a second that
this is merely a, uh, something to medicalize
name and then look at which pill can deal
with it.
I've dealt with a lot of, uh, compulsive liars
in my life.
I've told some of these stories before.
In a high school, I worked with people who
were compulsive liars and they would lie about
things much like Trump actually, where you
wonder, why would you lie about something,
number one, so insignificant.
And number two, so easily falsifiable.
I vividly remember a girl that I knew who
said that she had, you know, $600 glasses
or something like that.
And at the time I remember thinking, I know
that you don't, I know that, you know, at
the time, based on what things cost at the
time, nobody our age has $600 glasses.
Your glasses clearly aren't special.
They're normal glasses from the place down
the street.
But I didn't really understand what it was
about that that was appealing to her.
Why was it appealing to lie and claim that
she had $600 glasses and it probably connected
to some, uh, insufficiency that she felt elsewhere,
which she was trying to make up for with the
totally false notion that she owned this really
expensive thing that maybe people would find
interesting.
I, my reaction when I meet compulsive liars
and I've met a lot of them, is I don't even
react with any kind of surprise to the lies
they tell.
Because what I've sort of learned from experience
is that oftentimes the compulsive liar is
looking to generate a reaction and they feed
off of that reaction.
And they notice that when they tell these
lies, a lot of other people will react and
they will become more interested in the person
or they will react visibly in a way that sort
of fuels the person's desire to tell more
of these stories.
So I've dealt with people who say, yeah, it's
a, I actually, yeah, I mean I just can't,
I can't even think now, but there's so many
examples.
I just got back from a trip.
They actually got brought over to Japan.
I just spent two weeks there because I go
over there and do speeches and they, they
pay me 50 grand to speech and it's really
great and I know that the person has no money
and I know that they can barely afford rent.
And I know that they were asking another friend
of mine whether they could maybe move in together.
I don't even react.
Like I'm impressed.
I say, wow, that's really great.
Hmm, that's interesting.
And then I just move on to something else
that actually interests me.
And this will often, what really happens is
the person just stops being interested in
talking to me because I'm not giving them
the feedback that they want.
So that's my experience.
I find the compulsive lying very toxic, although
I am completely open to the idea that it connects
to childhood trauma or other conditions or
whatever.
I'm not saying compulsive liars or bad people
or anything like that, but for me, for the
way I like to live my life and the people
I like to be around, I just ignore the line
completely.
Pretend like everything is not only true that
they're saying, but so unremarkable that it's
like if they said, I bought, I bought a bananas
this morning.
Oh wow.
That's interesting.
Yeah, that's it.
I'm going to move on to something that's interesting
to me and typically they will distance themselves
because they want to be around people who
will react in the way that they like that
feeds the lying and often gets them to tell
more lies.
Let me know your experiences with compulsive
or pathological liars.
Interested to hear your take.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Become a member.
Join pacman.com or a patron at patrion.com/david
Pakman show to get instant access to the world
famous bonus track [inaudible]
the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].